les 35 heures toujours mais vu du côté
jardin tout au long de la semaine nous
vous présenterons des reportages sur la
manière dont les français occupent ce
nouveau temps libre loin des débats
politiciens les salariés se sont vite
adaptés
il profite de cette journée de congé
supplémentaire pour bricoler voyager ou
encore faire du sport rosen carnon jean
christophe duclos plus de temps pour
s'occuper de soi et garder la ligne
ça se voit les salles de sport comme
celle ci on s'enregistre est une
croissance de 10% l'an dernier et fait
rtt réduction du temps de travail les
habitudes changent matin après midi et
soir on élimine quand on veut justement
chi plus de sport avant je pouvais y
aller que le soir in quand ce n'est pas
des heures sup et balaj ménageant les
laissait pas plus qu'il n'y paraît
pikine aujourd'hui sauf d'être vous êtes
en rire c'était aujourd'hui je vis les
chenilles rg aujourd'hui urgent et fois
le vendredi soit lundi donc une bonne
occasion de faire un peu plus de sport
avant tout simple entre midi et deux
je courais à droite à gauche et la
direccte et des plages horaires plus
important que je viens ici trois heures
au lieu de trois quarts d'heure pour la
vase et pour moi surtout ça fait du bien
c'est plutôt le fait de décompresser
donc après mon match je sais pas si
bordeaux ne m'a pas vraiment pourquoi
mais en tout cas pour y perdre pour
répondre à cette nouvelle demande
il y a plus de cours collectifs l'après
midi le vendredi
l'activité est devenue intense sauf en
mai où les clients profiter de leurs 35
heures autrement les rtt pour moi donc
c'est donc je suis 4 s'est transformé en
journée complémentaire de congés j'ai
fait là
la route des vins d'alsace que je
n'aurais jamais fait j'ai fait aussi la
route napoléon que je n'avais jamais
fait aussi et puis d'autres petites
activités comme ça avec d'autres projets
encore dit les week-ends prolongés et le
produit en vogue chez les voyagistes 30%
d'augmentation leur base des premières
destinations la france deuxième l'italie
sans jus 40e rang avec mal france
revanche c'est parti à venise la femme a
offert un voyage à venise sur un sujet
vous en avez marre vous êtes crever il
fait pas beau vous partez trois quatre
jours au bout de quatre jours sur place
vous en avez un peu fait le tour dont
vous vous dites donc allonger recharger
les batteries je rentre et puis un mois
et demi après ben vous savez à nouveau
envie de faire la même chose et
aujourd'hui oublié pourquoi il veut pour
l'anniversaire de ma femme pour le
principe
autre événement au rayon sordi nager
bricolage grâce aux 35 heures les
français s'attaque aux gros travaux
les magasins l'ont compris celui ci
propose des stages gratuits
on a dans nos cartons un nombre
important de projets pour faciliter le
bricolage pour améliorer le bricolage
pour que les choses soient plus simples
pour que les gens perdent moins de temps
je crois que les 35 heures ne veulent
pas le dire qu'on a plus de temps mais
qu'on doit mieux gérer son temps le
ballet de caller aujourd'hui fosse
delloye twilight vous aimiez est en rtt
tous les jeudis madame à des appels
programme moi j'achète tout ce qui est
donc outils matériels et tous qui on
planifie deux jours avant l'e3 le jeudi
la tacle des travaux mais c'est pour
vous c'est quand même c'est plus une
contrainte ou c'est quand même un
plaisir le bricolage non non c'est un
plaisir
c'est un plaisir et puis les
transmetteurs mon père lui colle de
retrouver du travail un travail après
trois ans de chômage et du temps libre
après tout les 35 heures c'est bien fait
pour créer de l'emploi et libérer du
temps pour soi